[Música]
mijail gorbachov el ex líder soviético
que puso fin a la guerra fría de manera
pacífica murió a los 91 años de edad
tomó el poder en 1985 impuso reformas
internas además de abrir la unión
soviética al mundo pero no pudo evitar
su colapso por lo que hoy muchos rusos
lo tildan de traidor y fuera de su país
será ampliamente respetado gorbachov
ganó el premio nobel de paz en 1990 esto
por su papel en el fin de la guerra fría
sin embargo sigo siendo muy
despreciado en su casa los rusos lo
culparon por la disolución del anuncio
biótica en 1991 una superpotencia cuyo
territorio se fragmentó en 15 naciones
independientes salvamos entonces a
nuestro primer invitado el dial es diego
penny un historiador y doctor en
estudios rusos gracias diego por estar
con nosotros esta mañana de miércoles en
directo américa de france 24 hablemos
entonces principalmente por el legado de
mijail gorbachov porque fue tan tachado
por muchos soviéticos y qatar también
pues tildado como traidor en su país a
diferencia de occidente
era muy respetado
ahora buenos días muchas gracias por
invitación si es un problema complejo
cierto puesto que
pese a las reformas que impulsó en la
década de los 80 fueron presididas de
buena forma por la sociedad rusa y por
la unión soviética en general en la
década de los noventas que inauguró la
caída de la unión soviética es una
década bastante caótica de bastante
traumática desde distintos puntos de
vista desde perspectivas económicas
sociales demográficas e incluso
se inauguraron una serie de conflictos
al interior de la de las cenizas digamos
de lo que queda del anuncio ética que
hacen que el legado digamos que
gorbachov deja
la ex unión soviética sea uno
conflictivo y no he recordado
necesariamente de forma cariñosa
claro diego y precisamente también en
estos tiempos de guerra que vamos a
analizar pues ame a lo largo de nuestra
conversación pero hablemos ahora de la
perestroika una reforma para liberar la
economía llevada a cabo en estos últimos
años de la unión soviética en que fallo
bueno son varios factores cierto pero él
es buscar cierto liberar la totalidad de
la economía sobre una economía que había
estado como sabemos cierto organizada
sobre el principio centralmente
planificado y liberar digamos la fuerza
económica de forma
intempestiva durante la década de los 80
fue claramente un problema con el que no
se supo lidiar y claro en ese sentido la
las críticas que también vinieron
aparejadas con el desarrollo de la
glasnost fueron también factores que
comenzaron a girar digamos la opinión
pública en contra de la desde la
posición oficial y en ese sentido fue
una situación que comenzó a lentamente
de salirse de las manos y comenzó a ser
utilizada por otras haciendas políticas
que comenzaron a tener protagonismo
dentro del escenario ruso tanto la
perestroika como la glasnot fueron
digamos los principios de la caída de la
unión soviética hoy apostamos que
obviamente ya venía habilitada ya venía
con bastantes divisiones dentro de todos
los países que la integraban pero
digamos que estos fueron los dos
factores principales para la caída
bueno tú bien indicada desierto que
había factores habían
indicios de problemas anteriores cierto
que venían desarrollándose ya desde la
época de presión cierto la acumulación
de una deuda externa bastante grande que
hacían que la economía rusa se viera en
aprietos para poder llevar a cabo
reformas que fueran significativas
profundas y que tuvieran un efecto
positivo sobre la totalidad del sistema
económico soviético ya indicaban digamos
de que la unión soviética se encontraba
en un problema eso también si le sumamos
la situación internacional cierto con el
surgimiento del gobierno de reagan y la
posición más agónica aquí está todo
establecer el gobierno de eeuu durante
este período cierto durante la década de
los ochenta agudizaron los conflictos
que económicos y políticos que tenían la
unión soviética quienes se vieron en la
obligación también de comenzar a
aumentar el gasto en defensa etcétera y
todo lo que hay todo lo que ello implica
cierto cuando aumentaba las tensiones en
el contexto del aire y la mantención de
la variedad estratégica diego a lomos de
otro de los grandes éxitos de su
liderazgo del acuerdo firmado con eeuu
de las armas nucleares de corto y
mediano alcance además el fracaso de
gorbachov en su plan de la
desnuclearización completa
sí bueno eso fue tal vez uno de los
puntos más graves que que
hicieron probablemente que es el
problema de la guerra fría nuevo lugar a
ser resuelto y que al interior de la
unión soviética es cierto se le
considere como uno de los principales
arquitectos de la caída y de la pérdida
de prestigio mundial de rusia cierto
claro desde el punto de vista
internacional como señalan en el sexto
la sección anterior esto significó claro
una valorización muy grande a nivel
diplomático cierto por el hecho de ser
el arquitecto de un
sistema de paz mundial cierto pero claro
el interior denunció también eso
significó el
crear las condiciones para
el desmantelamiento del poder digamos
que sostenía la unión soviética como una
potencia internacional otras las cosas
importantes que pasó durante su
liderazgo fue el desastre nuclear de
chernobil también como esto lgl generó
puede jugar en contra no
claro y sobre todo en un contexto de la
de las no acepto en la que se haya
establecido una suerte de
apertura con respecto a la información
un fin casi total del sistema de censura
que se haya establecido en la unión
soviética desde la década de los 80